[Musique]
l'artiste il a encore frappé
mais de quoi tu parles de vieux démons
un copie 4 se cache derrière ce corps
l'artiste a marqué les esprits par la
façon dont il a tué et embaumé si femme
il les empoisonnaient il a rangé ensuite
leur corps les ornées de décoration et
les mettez en scène dans des structures
en métal les appeler ses œuvres
magistrales comment avez-vous fini par
l'attraper
d'enquêteur mené par une d'équipe
d'enquêteurs et l'un d'eux est justement
assis à côté de vous je mettrai pas un
pied dans cet endroit comment ça et bien
l'artiste va vouloir jouer au plus malin
pour voir si on peut gagner sa confiance
et ce sera impossible si je suis présent
dans la pièce étant donné ce qui s'est
passé entre nous en vérité il a ôté la
vie assez canderson il a été mon
coéquipier pendant 15 ans mais dans deux
semaines c'est va crier sur la
chaise et le monde se portera bien mieux
sans lui
aujourd'hui c'est parce que nous avons
parlé du camping-car je me suis dit
qu'en voyant les photos des victimes
vous pourriez remarquer quelque chose
qui pourrait nous aider
je veux que ma condamnation soit commuée
en enfermement à vie quel que soit
l'aide que je vous apporte je le fais
pour vous et uniquement pour vous
seriez-vous par hasard si le médecin
légiste lui aurait coupé les ailes
pourquoi c'est important son dernier
voyage vers l'au-delà elle est un ange
déchu en voyant en enfer
a créé une sculpture vient à résoudre un
mystère dès que j'aurai terminé vous
aurez l'adresse exacte terminer quoi de
sculpter de vous sculpter
vous êtes malade vous vous rendez compte
un cinglé
il a recommencé
[Musique]
de l'archange Samaël pourquoi je dois
écouter tout ça c'est vous Marie qui
serait la prochaine c'est toute ma vie
en photo tu dois la retirer
c'est l'essence même des cauchemars